hello and welcome to this video playing
the Z integrator yeah I always struggle
against the two wins five losses he's
one of those super quick players but he
still plays a good move so I'm going to
see what happens here hmm interesting
Ernest you for okay with the bishop open
does this feels a bit unconventional
let's say or uncommon whatever let's go
here and take the center directly yeah I
need a win yeah I below 2400 and I don't
like to be below that mark so we place
in gambit style okay what is the idea 95
maybe something like that okay I need to
develop so before no it tries to okay
ok I'll do here be ready for Knight to
c3 yeah I can play Knight c3 or five I
would like to play a fire but the move
Bishop a three years it's kind of
off-putting ok I'll jump in he might
spoil my castling but well I don't know
I can actually take with the night
doesn't do it what is this idea III here
maybe three but then I go e5 so
94 the screen deform I think now on I
defy them okay so what's the deal
what is he playing now not see them to
find a good movie of a wider
I'm also ready to play you fire soon
yeah this one hmm and thought just eat
five ok I want to be quick here I know
that I have lost games against because
of time management so let's be quick if
it takes twice on c3 i have a form
winning material and I'm ahead on the
clock
mmm two minutes down to two minutes so a
big time advantage I came yeah as so
okay Brooke is six I see SC SC SC but if
I go if I go rookie six he plays Knight
c8 and Bishop actually I have Bishop f8
though this is an interesting move
trying to make antiquey eight still push
up F 898 Bishop a3e takes d4 might be an
issue rookie seven gives away the
exchange push up F 898 we should a 3 e
takes d4 hmm
should be too
I'm a damaged this might be entirely
ridiculous maybe I should have thought
for a moment longer before I went for
that yeah I'm trapping his rook and I'm
still attacking the night so I hope and
think that I will win material but i'm
not entirely sure I might have I might
miscalculate okay it's taken this what
happens here um I can take the rook and
what is this at the end that might be
hmm it's very strange this is this is
very clear it's very strange queen is
696 is a very weird position but I can
check on you too and take the night I
have no idea what's going on ah this is
great I just have no idea so what now I
check him he might take and play rook e1
for something crazy but I'm gonna have
too much extra material here that won't
work
okay now i'm a piece up and c6 hangs so
shouldn't I keep this piece somehow
maybe but lots of things are hanging so
okay I'm taking this it's still a little
bit slow murky so pick up some see I
need to move the Queen here to being
able to move the night and I'd c3 is
actually interesting takes takes I don't
get on the back rang so I'll go here
ty morning so in exchange for a pawn and
then it's got d5 no that's stone let's
not do that check check look at that one
yeah those points will be dangerous and
let's see I cannot believe I'm spoiling
this stuff unbelievable I have a hard
time to stop the porno I cannot play
this oh my god i want any got a game by
me unbelievable God it was just
completely killed yeah and I lose this
winning ending al-jalil oh yeah Brooke a
one isn't super idiotic move this old
stuff I just have to just have to stay
on the D file and it's just an easy win
ah crazy and I have more time on the
clock how would your take is that this
is such a such a naive play look be one
it still wins I just have to go rook e1
or whatever but now no I just don't
think I just don't think here I just
play completely thoughtless stupid moves
ah unbelievable how can how come it's
how is it possible to lose that game I
really don't know sometimes what I'm
doing the whole game was was completely
one-sided yeah white was basically bed
after this move and he just got good
good completely killed and then you
don't win this childlike ending even
that is correct yep the computer has no
check no objections really amazing
really amazing
and check yeah I didn't simply I don't
know why would a for escape me can also
play this or whatever and then block on
the third-ranked you just have to
activate the king and win descending
when I just I just gifted him a million
moves I mean a million completely
thoughtless quick play I don't know I
was just blitzing out here just a little
bit of thought and I've got I've got
more time this is amazing yeah I think
here here this might already be lost
very likely after this I'm I'm
definitely losing this is what the
engine is playing and it says it it said
it gives equal maybe maybe it sees
something but i am not sure this check a
ok f porn if porn is quick check
check and then black my drone just about
I this is one of those games that i feel
it's really frustrating if you find all
the difficult moves yet and I'll play
the guy and then in this technical
position i'm just saying completely my
chest up it is not difficult it's not
like I cannot play this kind of position
and I'm too bad to do it I just don't
think I don't know I just play
completely mindless moves yeah I think
this I'm relaxing this is a typical
problem I relax too early when I think
okay now the job is done basically am
and then I'm relaxing and I allow stuff
that is totally unnecessary to allow
yeah I mean losing with black in this
position is it's really really hard okay
thanks for watching